my mindset is like an investment mindset
i invested into something
bad
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and i'm about to introduce you to an
absolutely incredible guy he's a
musician he's an artist philanthropist
business owner property entrepreneur
completely financially free i've been
coaching now for a few years and his
rent to rent business is turning over 25
to 30 000 pounds per
month so if you want to learn about rent
to rent you want to learn about mindset
you want to learn about the
technicalities of property then he's
going to be absolutely breaking down
what he did how he did it how you can do
the same thing too but the first thing
you need to do of course to be a
property entrepreneur is you need to hit
like on these videos subscribe and uh
welcome back to the channel so jay
what's going down brother thank you so
much for coming down to my house it's
been a long time coming i know god i've
been uh looking forward to this moments
in a long time so you've been um improv
now for a few years yeah talk me through
how you got started in property i know
you're also a musician so what was the
first deal that actually landed
so the first it actually landed was a
deal in huddersfield okay in
huddersfield so
um what happened to this one i i found
well before that i had a different deal
that also landed but that would also
fail through the landlord was happy but
as soon as i introduced the investor
i just got replied back from the state
and saying the landlord doesn't want to
carry everything that was it and i think
that was because maybe the landlord
thought
um you told me you're going to take it
on and then why is someone else coming
aboard there's a few setbacks oh yeah i
had a lot of setbacks like you know for
like a year between
20 the whole 2019 yeah i was pretty much
just thinking you know what i'd give up
on this stuff really because of what
happened with that deal the fair fruit
um so i decided to take a break of
property because after all those
rejections that differently through i
was like nah this is not for me so i
gave up
um
i quit that was it
yeah busting your ass off yeah and then
quit
and you could have eased i could have
maybe had you on losers on a
tuesday the people it didn't work out oh
yeah you should have paid for the
training quicker
but did i tell the training i would have
found a way yeah i've been forward
i would have found a way to to introduce
him
and you could have eased i could have
maybe had you on losers on a tuesday
for the people it didn't work out yeah
people that failed exactly
you know like you can only learn so much
on youtube and youtube will teach you a
lot yeah don't get me wrong but
having a mentor and something actually
guides you yeah i think it's crucial so
yeah tell me the story of some of the
because i think it's important people to
hear and learn from the mistakes exactly
so after the first deal fell through
because of the the article 4 and the
licenses and hmo licenses i i went to
the crash course that was my first crash
course i went to
um i learned a lot there was so useful
like the information i let there like
how to calculate material investment how
to analyze the deal you gave us quite a
few spreadsheets it's always just quite
useful so i went back and started
looking for
for more deals to source to people so i
can start sourcing become a new source
yeah
and obviously use that money to start
investing my own deals
so i targeted manchester
i started for service accommodations in
manchester
you went and did that financial freedom
challenge with glee yes so i watched
that that just pumped me up again yeah i
was like no i have to try this again
so so i went viewed so many houses in
sheffield what might you what did you
choose sheffield
and because that's where i'm from are
you from sheffield i'm from sheffield
yeah okay but you've now gone to
manchester united
so when you saw me go to sheffield with
nothing yeah that become financially
free what do you think that was that was
incredible that that's what i was
thinking like this is not real like i
have to try myself yeah and and and i
did and i did and uh it's worked out
branched out a little bit more into
huddersfield and and few other places
and i found this deal in huddersfield
the deal was was perfect but the money
that i wanted to pay for for the for the
property yeah was too too little for
what the landlord wanted but then the
stage and money managed to visit the
landlord but because the landlord was
didn't know anything about um about rent
rent he went and spoke to his solicitor
and selected solicitor basically
advising not to do anything right
already right he said it's the thing
also known as rent
right so that deal fell through so i
thought right so this estate agent he's
willing to work with me on regular basis
yeah
so
what what i did is i went and looked on
the estate agent's website for other
properties
that would potentially be good rent rent
how do you get a rental rate
you get ready to rent by looking for
land for estate agents
that understand the model okay because
at the moment there's like so many
people doing this
you would even find any stage and that's
they've worked with other people that
are doing this and they don't like it or
just say no
and all you follow the stage and that
they've worked with someone who's done
this and they like him and he's like yes
we're willing to take more people like
you
and all your finance agent that does not
include what a rental rent is and what's
the best the best is finding the person
does work to find other people and they
understand the model so they get it yeah
okay
and how do you find them is it a numbers
game or is there a skill to it i i
reckon you
take a list of all your estate agents in
the area that you're looking for
call them and just say
um i'm
are you familiar with rent to rent
yes no yes is it yes about someone or no
oh yes and i don't like it
hang up call to the next person until
you find that one is the agent that's
like yeah we actually got this type of
person to work with because
that that's guaranteed to happen because
in every city that has
and people that do rentman's they go
they work for estate agents and you are
going to find these stages about [ __ ] so
it's about quickly finding that agent
that understands the business model yeah
why is an estate agent better than a
landlord because landlords i know
some landlords goes with their emotions
and you have to try to convince them if
if they don't know that the model you
you have to try and solve like and
landlords so of course it's their
property they'll take it personal yeah
wherefore
they'll be like ah do i really want to
let this guy in there and so on and so
on by the state agent is like
you know it's a business you know you
approach him in a way like
i'm a company
i want a property on a
business lease yeah five ten years
um
that's why it is it's not forget rental
rent i'm taking it on a business list
and then i'll run my business how many
rooms how many rooms have you currently
got right now
44 rooms 44 yeah there's 44 rooms
how many of those 44 units
how many
agents have you had to go through until
i want to go one two three three three
so three agents yeah 44 rooms yeah
that's literally three people that have
said yes yes that's three yeses yeah so
21 listen to this right now you're three
yeses away
from 12 grand profit a month just three
yeses yeah how do you find out how do
you find out the how do you find out the
demand in area
spare rules okay you pull like a like a
fake cardboard from spare room yeah so
once you finally locate like you've come
to an agreement with a landlord
um and then you put albertos payroll
with that specific location yeah and
then like a dummy ad like a dummy ad
yeah and then
you see the demand before you sign the
agreement you usually take you should
start seeing results within
within a week within a day the same day
many more i'm aiming for stupid two
people inquiring from the room so yeah
in a week you found it you get 14 people
what's you've been like working with me
amazing amazingly like easy to work with
i was helping so
and and one thing i appreciate about you
is the fact that um
this is what i noticed when when i came
to to the new study masterclass you told
everyone what they need to do you gave
them tasks
you gave them all the information and
you didn't just let it go there you told
them as well
if you need any help
you can reach out to me you can reach
out to tony you can reach out to this
person so if you don't reach out to
people that is your fault
you know i mean you giving people like
everything there and you give them
further help after the you know the
training so i don't see how anyone could
go wrong unless they're lazy unless they
they're just not putting in the room
because even like even today you know
what was it a couple days ago when you
reach out to me exactly asking me for
the contract for this contract that
contract yeah i think you're right i
think if you work hard and when you get
stuck you ask for help that's the right
people yeah you kind of can't fail and i
think what you would probably do in the
first year the reason you probably
struggled so much is because you weren't
asking for help yeah exactly that you
didn't have anyone to ask about yourself
you were alone yeah but actually
no man is in ireland yeah exactly no
yeah it's better to get around good
people
so uh dude you're a winner man tell
about your song that just came out yeah
so i've just released a song called the
you know called gold diggers
okay is that evening
it's just an experience you know that
i've had through life um it's not
necessarily gold because of just female
there's gold because that melts as well
and you know you get people that they
see doing good then they come around you
and turn it from your plate yeah
i mean have you had that much oh you
love a lot right yeah yeah everyone
wants a base if it was a piece yeah you
know because
they see you doing well you they expect
you to pay for everything and and so on
and so on which is obviously you know
it's fine if
if we were
grafting together if
me and you were with day ones and you're
struggling i'm happy to help you
but you know if i don't know you then
you know
show me that
you know you you know you're not just
here because
i'm i'm living a good lifestyle yeah you
know
also you know contribute then once you
become friends then maybe i can i can
people want to take you out for coffee
to pick your brand and then they can't
even be bothered to go to a crash course
and then they won't really use that
knowledge yeah and you just feel like
why am i telling you all my stuff and
you know they're just curious you're
just curious exactly they're not trying
to just be nosy so what does an average
data like for you then jay
so an average day i'm still i still got
a full-time job and if you're not wow
yeah what are you doing engineering
design engineering so you've designed it
but you've employed your sister to work
full-time on your property business yeah
how important is is getting around
having the right people around you
having the right friends and support
group around you it's very very very
important because you need to have
people they can rely on yeah these are
people that can rely on and
i've had friends back in lyon yeah you
know
all my
life so it's been great well dude man
congrats for everything you've done
congrats on the music
on the on the success in business and
property yeah and uh looking forward to
helping you scale things now take things
a whole new level definitely that's a
big respect you enjoyed the interview
what an awesome guy why don't you go
ahead and just drop like also if you
want to come and you want to come to the
property investors crash course where
you can learn all the foundation
information that you need to go and
scale the property business guess what
i've got a few limited tickets available
click the link below and get yourself
booked on subscribe
[Music]
[Music]
my phone telling me
you